welcome back to CBS this morning
there is a disturbing newly released
surveillance video and it shows a
teenager being forcibly restrained by at
least seven men at a Michigan youth
facility the teenager died two days
later we have to warn you here that the
video is graphic it happened in April in
the cafeteria at Lakeside Academy that's
in Kalamazoo after Cornelius Frederick's
threw a sandwich according to the State
Health Department he was restrained for
about 12 minutes
his family's attorneys say that
Frederick screamed out I can't breathe
three staff members face criminal
charges national correspondent Drita
Duncan is following this story for us
this is the moment that appeared to
start the confrontation 16 year old
Cornelius Frederick's threw a sandwich
in the cafeteria moments later staffer
Michael Mosley tackled Frederick's to
the ground two other men soon joined him
to restrain the teen for about 12
minutes Frederick's is pinned to the
ground at least four more men came over
and appeared to hold down Frederick's
his arms and legs and sit on his chest
and abdomen towards the end of the video
you can see Frederick's go limp he went
into cardiac arrest and died after two
days in the hospital
the coroner ruled his death a homicide
by asphyxiation fiber represents
Cornelius Frederick's the state day when
you see five six seven grown men sitting
on the chest of a motionless child until
he's dead staffers will Mosley Zachary
Solis and nursing director Heather
mclogan were all fired from Lakeside
Academy and charged with involuntary
manslaughter and second degree child
abuse attorney Tasi Marku represents
Heather mclogan who was also charged for
not providing timely aid but Marku says
anyone could have given Frederick CPR
that day when you look at all the
evidence and I'm confident when all the
evidence comes in she will be vindicated
in a statement to CBS this morning an
attorney for Michael Mosley said Mr
Mosely was following protocol at all
times the reason for the initiation of
the restraint was due to Frederick's as
threats to children of eminent physical
violence speaking for the first time
about the incident
Zachary Solis says he helped restrain
Frederick's and was following his
training what specifically are you
taught to do in terms of where you grab
someone on how you hold them during this
restraint when you're restraining
someone like that are you waiting to
hear from the person you're restraining
that they give up attorney Donald's the
panas represents the least I think the
facility itself is running for the hills
and hiding behind these these young
people that were called upon to do their
job they're not they're not medical
personnel when you learn that he passed
away what was your reaction
Cornelius Frederick's had been a ward of
the state for several years his mother
died years before and his father lost
custody of his son when he went to
prison Frederick's leaves behind four
siblings this institutional violence
goes on far too often and the children
are powerless and they're voiceless and
no one's out on the street protesting
Cornelius Frederick's brutal and
ruthless killing lakeside Academy has
since been shut down and its license
revoked its residents were moved to
another location now in a statement to
CBS News sequel youth and family
services tells us that they operated at
sequel they said they emphasize
de-escalation both with our staff and
our students it is our policy they say
to only use restraints as an emergency
safety intervention we are committed to
making the necessary changes to ensure
something like this
ever happens again alive Jericka this is
such a horrible story and to know from
your reporting that Cornelius
Frederick's had been a ward of the state
his mom died his father lost custody and
now he has died because he threw a
sandwich tarika thank you very much